let's jump to uh this thread from drew
this one
democrat hypocrisy but i want to start
by saying this ladies and gentlemen
this is the end what we're seeing the
utter hypocrisy from democrats and media
pundits
cannot survive progressives
are already tweeting smack talking the
democratic establishment in the media
establishment
obviously not every single one but many
of them are saying we did not vote for
this
there's one there's one twitter account
that's getting memed around like crazy
because they were like
i'm deactivating my account i did not
realize biden would do this this is
wrong
we didn't want war he lied to us i think
about barack obama
he did the same thing but there was no
twitter right so what happens is
we can see the hypocrisy we can see
gensake
press secretary saying under what
authority is donald trump bombing syria
what about now when joe biden 36 days in
does the same thing
we can see all of these democrats and it
is it is
stamped in our mind so what happens now
is the younger generation
they're going to see these tweets and be
like yeah these people lied that's it
right war is bad we don't want this i
say this at the end what i mean
is that the establishment stranglehold
and ability to keep lying
is weakening i'm optimistic in this
regard yeah because i it is
you know i've asked how is it that so
many people still fall for the
mainstream media
they're probably older people watching
tv younger people aren't now many of
these younger people probably fall for
garbage emotional manipulation from a
lot of these leftist
grifters but let's pull this thread we
have from
the man himself drew holden and your
tweet reads
it seems not all pointless foreign wars
are created equally
in the eyes of the democrats the media
and the chattering class when trump hit
syria it was an outrage
but under biden well apparently things
are different do you want to just read
through some of the tweets we'll show
them and yeah
break down for what you found i i will
so i was going through it today and i
looked and i saw a lot of the
i was reminded very quickly what
happened in 2017 and 27
2018 where there was enormous criticism
of donald trump history i'm sure i was
probably critical of it too i thought i
was like yeah i'm not sure i'm well
about this one like i criticize
i'm getting these people tweeting at me
and they're like the haters the
tribalists
and they're like are you gonna do you
know criticize biden no you wouldn't
criticize trump and i was like i i did
i criticized trump on the syria thing
like every video people complained about
it
you get it to him you're mad at trump
for firing tomahawk missiles into syria
and i'm like ah what am i gonna
i'll complain about it i supported tulsi
keffert yeah exactly
the tribalists are full of it i lost so
many followers when i went after trump
for doing those moves he's like no
trump's doing the right thing i'm like
no and i remember calling him out
aggressively and losing a large ton of
followers and i was like i don't care uh
goodbye and they're like you
you're like cnn uh you're trump
syndrome i'm like no i have principles
something a lot of people you know
so what you discovered so what i found
very quickly was that
for whatever reason all of the people
who were incredibly critical in 2017 and
2018 uh were not
critical or the best one i think the one
i started off with so usually the way i
structure these is
i'll hit the uh the members of congress
first and then the media and then
whoever write blue checks
but the first one i had to start it with
is a phenomenal side by side it's
lawrence o'donnell of msnbc fame
when back in 2018 he had tweeted dear
news media
if you think trump has constitutional
authority to attack syria please say why
if you're not sure please ask the
question please stop using the phrase
constitutional crisis
as it can only refer to firing people
not missiles right
a lot of concerns very concerned with
lawrence o'donnell then
lo and behold yesterday last night right
after all this goes down
he tweets out a link to his upcoming
show that has ben
rhodes um failed mfa uh
a failed short story writer turned uh
policy wonk apparently ben rhodes
and lawrence o'donnell tweets ben rhodes
has been in the room when
the president orders a proportional
response and he has them on and they
talk about why
this this specific attack made total
sense complete in total sense well you
look drew you you just misunderstand
it is always it has always been the
position of the democrats that
bombing syria is a good thing now the
issue isn't that donald trump
was bombing syria the issue was that the
man who ordered them happened to have
been orange
it makes sense now yes it's a night and
day difference and so i think
it's interesting because a lot of
democratic politicians very much went
with that sort of mentality and thread
my favorite nancy pelosi she tweeted
this is
in 2017. so right after these first
strikes retweet if you agree which is
a horrible thing to put in a tournament
right
in terms of a little twitter 101 please
the love of god don't do that retweet if
you agree that congress has a
responsibility to immediately debate
president trump's actions in syria
which is hysterical because back then in
2017
she had no power to bring everyone back
in and
force everyone to have this conversation
she is now the speaker of the house
who could call back congress tomorrow
she could force them to have this
conversation
for whatever reason no interest weird
but perhaps actually i take that back my
my favorite among elected officials has
to be barbara lee she used a couple of
uh
a couple of emojis i think it's
questionable it's dubious
the first was the shouting emoji all
capped trump doesn't have the authority
to have troops in syria much less to
protect oil
apparently biden does and then again
twitter 101 please don't do this
producing foreign oil clap hands is clap
hands
not clap hands hey clap hands legitimate
dance military
clap hands mission clap hands just do
the class stop endless
protecting foreign oil is not a
legitimate
military mission stop endless war thanks
i hate it
like no follow-up from her for whatever
reason i mean maybe i can turn on the
news i don't know because
friday is often not a working day in
congress so maybe she just hasn't heard
did you try to contact them be like hey
do you have a do you have a point on
that
i i should well so obviously i always
tag these people whenever i tweet at
them and for whatever reason i haven't
heard anything back on those ones
that's strange what is this a
proportional response to
there was there was a rocket strike on
an iraqi uh military base yeah that
killed an american contractor
so joe biden said oh i'm gonna blow them
up
allegedly that's what they say right we
have to understand what they say
is usually a lot different than what
actually happened yeah and
and and more importantly there were
reports going around as soon as biden
got in that u.s troop movements in syria
started escalating
and we saw western news sources saying
that's not true it's a myth that's this
is totally normal
and then we saw you know middle eastern
sources saying the us is running troops
through syria yeah
and then the new york times i believe
had the best take today they had an
article that was titled u.s
airstrike in syria targets iran-backed
militias
in that article it literally says and i
quote
little is known about this group
including whether it is backed by iran
what literally that's yes that's
literally what they said so again
a lot of information is very sporadic
it's very hard to believe
a lot of anonymous government sources
are coming out and they're not putting
their name behind this but they're
saying this was defensive wow
anonymous government source new york
times yup little is known about the
group including whether it is backed by
iran or related to organizations that
use the facilities
for uh the american air strikes targeted
on thursday let's go right to the top
of the title yeah u.s airstrikes in
syria target iran-backed
militias they are lying clap
clap
in a lot of ways the media can speak
these sorts of things into existence the
new york times had another story
with strikes with strikes in syria biden
confronts iran's militant network yes i
saw that right it's the same thing it's
if you repeat
it this is this is wmd's all over again
if you just repeat it over and over and
over again
it becomes part of the conversation
another big thing to realize here
the iranian forces in syria are the ones
that are partly responsible
for crushing isis al-qaeda and al-nusra
and other sunni radical groups
the iranians are basically shiite groups
that
are fighting against the sunnis and if
it wasn't for the iranians and the
syrians working together
isis would still have a huge foothold
inside of syria so
by biden and by donald trump attacking
the syrian government they're attacking
the people that are stopping isis
that's spreading radical jihadism and
terrorism all over the west
that's another point here that you know
oddly that point was forgotten by the
mainstream media they forgot to mention
that one for some reason
under trump isis was crushed was that
correct yeah i think so yeah well they
lost a lot of their funding that was
given to them by barack obama and
hillary clinton and then he blew up the
the main dude
yeah yeah yeah well russia also took a
large part in that and exposed how a lot
of the oil that was being uh you know
siphoned in by isis was actually traded
to turkey russia exposed how there was
caravans working with the turkish
military along with isis
usually financing terrorism saudi arabia
israel also financed the sunni larger
wahhabist terrorist groups in there
israel by the way was given advanced
notice of this airstrike
and they released the statement that
they're very pleased that this airstrike
happened in that particular
region so there's a lot of different
geopolitical things happening but
essentially
i boil it down to the larger class of
civilization civilizations that's
happening in the middle east between the
sunnis and the shiites
the sunnis the radical islamists are on
the side of israel so
they're they're they're saying in the
media over and over again iran yeah
ronnie round around around around deep
down they say oh we don't know for sure
but we're gonna keep saying their name
over and over again so how long until we
have war with iran
i mean they've been they've been trying
to do this john bolton said what did
john bolton say
by this time next year we will be
celebrating in tehran he was wrong on
his timeline but we have to understand
what syria is it's not about syria syria
is a larger proxy war between the united
states
russia and also china in some ways china
has actually even sent
some support to the syrians china has a
very close relationship with the
iranians so does russia
so there's probably going to be another
proxy war just like we're seeing in
yemen
just like we're seeing in syria just
like we've seen already play out
in um in libya that's going to take
place in iran but another big thing to
really kind of calculate here and
understand this larger web
that the military industrial complex
paints to you
is the fact that it was the fir it was
the gulf war
after 2001 in 2003 when the gulf war was
launched
that made iran such a powerhouse in
the middle east region because it got
rid of one of their chief competitors
iraq
and their sphere of influence actually
grew they became more
powerful because of the war in iraq so
again
these neoconservatives literally created
the boogeyman
and we could even talk about the cia
coup in the 50s
and and all this other stuff but but the
the fingerprints on the
military-industrial complex
on the neoconservatives is literally
create the boogeyman let's finance isis
let's make iran more popular in the
region and let's go to war with them
next they're literally creating their
own problems that they're now coming to
you and saying well we have to
you know we can't give you that two
thousand dollar check we can't give you
fifteen dollars minimum wage we got this
huge threat we gotta fight that
conveniently we made happen and and
that's the big lie
sold to the american people who just
conveniently keep forgetting american
history
i'm doing clapbacks
but i'm just absolutely flabbergasted
and so disappointed in people especially
in the mainstream media
that don't talk about these events in
relevant uh
timelines that actually give people a
perspective to see what's happening here
because
we are essentially paying for the
destruction of this country by putting
us in these quagmires meanwhile china
they're having our lunch they're they're
probing our diplomats and they're going
to
going to be doing a lot more with their
global hegemony which they're going to
take over with
their policies rather than our
self-destructive hurting policies that
put us in debt
and send our american troops into harm's
way for what we've got we actually have
a
breaking news we have exclusive oh yeah
an exclusive photograph of joe biden
actually making the switch between
giving checks to the american people and
dropping a bomb and as you can see he's
wearing a leather jacket and a
what is that fedora is that a cool
that's what happened you know what you
know it's really sad
i'm not mad i'm sad all of these twitter
accounts from these progressives who are
like but we thought biden was the good
guy
good but you thought it was a good guy
oh poor baby at least they're waking up
listen i'm not i'm i'm annoyed i don't
want to be mean
we i think we're old enough to where we
experience the obama years we knew what
obama was gonna do or we knew what obama
did we knew what biden was gonna do
and we kept saying it over and over
again and they're like yeah but trump is
a fascist
okay well you know have more war i guess
we're gonna go to war with russia
let's see how that plays out that's the
next trump was a fascist not no
not any more or less than any other
president that's not a fascist well this
country is fascist
no it is it's built on the backs of
slaves and corporate
corporatocracy that's fascism no it's
it's suitable for us
but you know it's basically controlling
the world through military coercion it's
not fashionable it's attempting to
there's a there's a lot going on in the
world it's not like dictatorial fascism
no you're using fascism as a general
term for like
corporations have been dude raytheon ceo
is now our defense secretary is that
what it is
yeah that's crony capitalism it sure is
but we're allowed to talk about it it's
not fascism well it's not like it's
fascinating
fascism it's just like no subversive
fascism was
the fact that they're not coming in here
are kicking our door and then you know
probing us it's just that we're not
but if we we if we allow these people if
we allow these people to keep doing
these things eventually it will be
yeah it's especially under joe biden
it's a it's an information war you're
right
and it doesn't have to happen in iran if
as long as we keep the communication
going and keep people aware
that we should not be going into iran if
these bombings are out of order then i
think we won't go well another thing to
kind of add here just really quickly
is the fact that china's taking over the
world through trade
we're taking it over through military
blunders that indebt us forever and
that's not achieving anything
iraq wants us to leave syria wants us to
leave there was an iraqi parliament that
literally voted
please the united states leave the
united states decided not to do that and
not to listen to a direct
government order by the iraqi government
and that's
that's when we had these mysterious kind
of rocket attacks that
somehow are justifying our our our
bigger involvement in there i'm not
putting on any theories out there
i'm just saying it was very convenient
of a timeline that did happen
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time